what do you think of Bryson since she
lived there for a long time yeah I I've
got asked because now I'm like I'm like
because like
I I Joey was like you met Garn right and
I was like no I never met going what are
you talking about
I'm like you definitely and then in my
rets and I have like an image of you
like far away and then he's like no you
shook hands I'm like
and then I listened to the so many
episodes of this [ __ ] podcast and
then you'd all of a sudden drop like oh
yeah my hometown bright and I'm like
Brighton
oh [ __ ] I've seen God yeah you literally
I literally came to pick me and knock
you out from his house actually it was
it was funny because I met Felix for the
first time like two three weeks ago and
Phoenix like oh Joey said we met and I'm
like no we haven't yeah
Joe's just making [ __ ] up why would he
say that I've never met you
you shook him and then we shook hands
and I'm like yeah Joey's such a liar
we're in like the lift or something and
then Felix was like yeah he was saying
like I went to your house or something
and I was like
it was funny uh yeah we kind of randomly
just moved to Brighton yeah because you
stayed there for a while yeah it was
kind of like the YouTuber Hub of the UK
right yeah yeah it doesn't really feel
like it anymore in a weird way yeah
because I left yeah because he left now
it's Japan I thought it felt like when
you know the UK was at its peak of
youtubing
the ukulele era yeah and then now it
doesn't matter
and every UK vlogger had a ukulele that
they could play as well yeah that was
the good old days it doesn't really feel
like UK has much YouTube stuff going on
yeah
they do they do like the sidemen are
like massive oh yeah I mean that that
yeah those are those those guys are
massive YouTubers are [ __ ] their
pants because PewDiePie's here oh yeah
come and take over everyone yeah you're
not the biggest in Japan anymore so yeah
well you seem to be enjoying doing your
Vlogs yeah it's really fun
[Music]
it works I think it works because
YouTube is show like intense intense
intense I spent one billion dollars yeah
so I could get Mr BEAST's attention for
10 seconds I feel like though that
Style's almost coming back is like an
answer on YouTube right it's like
everyone like misses like the Nostalgia
of that kind of style of video it really
works though I just feel bad for Chris
you know like Chris's put so much effort
in and then oh and then up comes Felix
being like yeah whatever the top J
vlogger in Japan I'm sorry Chris
yeah
Brighton I just not gonna look bad yeah
yeah because um you grew up there yeah I
grew up there that's crazy and uh when I
grew up there it wasn't even a city it
was like a town like it was Brighton
like Brighton and hope were two separate
towns and then they were like what if we
like cheated the system and they just
murdered it and just merged it yeah it
makes no sense I'm like guys we are now
a city guys we were drawing a circle
around here don't worry it's a city now
that's happened a lot in the UK it's
happened a lot in the UK yeah a lot of
especially London a lot of the boroughs
and stuff change and they all merge and
stuff it happens a lot in the UK well
London a lot of Wars as well you know
yeah yeah that's true change the
landscape quite a lot like yeah what
made you want to move to Brighton
originally because uh growing up yeah we
were just lazy I guess well London
wasn't in your options no London's too
busy and then me and Marzia we spoke
English to each other yeah right we're
like
neither of us wanted to learn each
other's languages yeah let's go to UK
it's not too far away right it seems
cool it was yeah but then I think we
overstay our welcome a bit right yeah
yeah I'm sorry this is so windy and
great all the time it is it's almost
like the seat it just felt a bit
depressing after a while winter in
Brighton is just yeah yeah so you just
get battered by wind and rain yeah I
don't know if it's a storm oh yeah
[ __ ] time you didn't want to uh you
didn't want to move to Wales
you went to where did you go in Wales
don't remember you went to like the
really weird Mediterranean looking oh
yeah that was cool that was fun yeah I
remember I posted photos of that and
everyone from Wales was like this is not
my Wales experience it's way too sunny
and nice
we did get one week of sun we get one
week of Sunrise
I was like damn well this is actually
awesome yeah yeah it was really cool
thanks I'll take that to my grade yeah
I feel like it got cool after you moved
there because I grew up in Brighton
right and I did like my entire life I'm
like I can't wait to get out of the city
and suddenly you move here and then I
come I came back to visit like for the
past few years I'm like when the [ __ ]
did this city get so cool it's hustling
inbox it's hipster the city yeah there's
like so many good restaurants so many
hip places I'll wait for Pub crawling
exactly I was like where was this when I
was growing up oh really you didn't get
that I don't know I didn't
like it was like only cool during like
some months in the summer that was it
that was a good two thing to do in
Brandon growing up the beach oh yeah
that was it that was it that was nice
and that's you know that's that's why
like it's kind of like Stockholm
syndrome where I'm like Brian has a good
beach in my heart it in my heart I know
it
a chill Place cool place is it a good
beach I don't know probably not I mean
Joey Joey comes there from Sydney yeah
he probably hates it yeah I remember I
remember when I first went to go visit
gone in Brighton it was my first time in
the UK ever and God's like oh yeah we
can have like the weather's nice today
so we can go down to the beach I'm like
sick all right I like beaches let's go
and I show up and I'm like where is it
I'm like where's the beach and he's like
you go all these rocks they're like
sweet can I go in the water nope
you can you can you can you just don't
want it yeah it's kind of gross but yeah
it's yeah it's gross it's cold yeah I
took one look at the beach I'm like I'm
not going in that water I'm sorry I have
a girl it's fine yeah yeah you're fine
could you really enjoy it without
getting like recognized all the time
beaches rough yeah yeah that's kind of
how it we felt like we enjoyed Japan a
lot because no one recognized yeah but
British people are cool they're nice I I
like have you been recognized since
being here uh because there's not really
a lot of foreign
it's kind of did you even have internet
here like I don't know
well the train from London to Wales the
moment I go out of London I just get no
internet and I can't load anything and
it's like [ __ ] it's fun though I love it
I mean I I prefer the food in Wales to
like the rest you get really fresh meat
sorry they're fresh meat I don't care
I'm just saying why did you say
italicize me
no I I there's the pubs are like amazing
in Wales um if they have more pubs than
anywhere else in the world per like
square meter or something it's stupid
there's nothing
[Music]
[Music]
are they including Hove as well
and
was 320 .
so while there's no official stat it is
widely regarded speculated that
aberduster is in Wales is home to the
most pubs per square mile in the UK
Pub subscriber how many how many pubs
Jack in there is in a square mile square
mile of habitat I don't [ __ ] know yes
damn it 50 no 50. originally 53 pubs
yeah that's where I'm from it's nice
until so certain areas are not oh really
it's nice yeah it's gone yeah I liked it
a lot where did you go in Wells because
we we asked Connor like if you want to
go [ __ ] weird like how do you
remember them it's almost like they're
in a different ways are they speak in
another language
is impossible to remember yeah yeah
every time an English person tells me
they went to Wales like a trip that like
I went to
uh
yeah oh I know there actually it is
funny driving through there and seeing
all the signs like there's no [ __ ]
way that's real there's no way
it's a fine language thank you very much
Ikea names there's no way that's real
I like to buy a vowel please okay that's
bothering I want to show you where you
wait where you went now I gotta remember
the name I mean you've been to quite a
few uh places where I like countries and
stuff like that like what would you say
is there like one place right now that
you really really want to go that's like
on the top of your bucket list because
other than Japan obviously ah Japan was
like big on our bucket list I think uh
going further from Iceland oh you kind
of sucks a bit because that's a really
cool place to visit yeah we really want
to go that's why that's number one of my
problems that's super fun I really love
Iceland yeah and people think I'm
Icelandic too which makes me feel like
yeah
[Music]
I'm faster internet Sweden they have the
same snacks as Sweden yeah for the
architecture it feels really nice check
out the comments to tell me where you
are but everyone's just like come to
Georgia it's better it's like what oh oh
it's in London yes yes
I know that place yeah I know we went up
north and around in a circle oh that's
good that's good there's some really
rough Parts up north really yeah oh yeah
people warned about that where they on
they don't speak English to you
it never happened
let's do the historical stuff but like
they're the north uh Northwest is the
most Wall Street because oh okay but
they'll still speak English to you oh
okay I remember I tried to speak Russian
people and they were like no what yeah
they were like no they're on people I
was like you betrayed me
yeah yeah well this is cool Iceland's
good yeah
I don't want to go yeah and it's it's
like weird that now that I've moved out
I hate how you two were literally right
[ __ ] next to it the entire time and
you're like bro broke what do you want
me to do I had no money for so long
well and I would I would not be able to
buy any food when I go out I'll be like
I'll go to the family listen I'm from
Australia which is going to be the polar
opposite of Iceland in terms of distance
yeah it's weird because now that I've
like moved out of Europe and the UK when
I was living there I just wanted to go
to Asia and I like traveled to Asia
every day on holiday and now I just want
to go back to Europe yeah and then I did
not take advantage of that yeah